in addition to that I got into some
voice acting work where I worked for a
cult here in Japan where I did the
voices
[Music]
how did this opportunity come around
well this was actually one of the first
uh opportunities I had was because when
in nigata I met a member of that church
and they they said you have such a
lovely voice and I was like
you know you should do work for our our
El cantare or whatever and I was like
what I was like no I haven't had that on
the menu yet I was like what's that
they're like no they were like no no
that's uh that's the great when I was
like oh okay I just heard that like you
know and so I came to Tokyo and it was
like when I was so young man and um well
I was 31.
and then I was young comparatively
I had to clarify that but like we we go
in there and um I I go into this this
this gilded building it's this 18-story
massive place they have them all around
Japan and I I go in there and they were
like yeah welcome and I swear to God I'm
not making this up the girl who was like
the receptionist yeah must have been 21
22 23 really young really attractive and
she had the suzaisan dog as a stuffed a
big stuffed animal yeah a hugged to her
chest and she was like welcome and she'd
say like can you say welcome and then
she would like talk as the dog to me and
I was like all right let's go and so I
was like uh which one do I reply to do I
talk to a dog dude I was like hi hi you
know and so they were like all right
well we gotta go up to the top floor and
we have your script ready and stuff and
I said okay we go to the top and um the
script had way too many English mistakes
like it was it was incomprehensible yeah
like it didn't even make any sense so
they said all right well we'll wheel out
the YouTube YouTube videos of his
speeches and then you can just read that
along but with you know like him yeah
and I said okay well set it up for me
what's the deal and they were like all
right do you know like who Jesus is I
was like yes
I'm aware I've heard the name before
they were like all right imagine that
you can hear Jesus talking to you I was
like okay I went to Catholic school for
a year I know what that's like they're
like man Santa and I was like
I was like that's a very different voice
and then they were like and you have
like the prophet Muhammad or you have
um alcantare which I guess is another
being or Buddha or any she listed like
nine or ten different royalties yeah and
and she said when you hear their voices
which is what our leader hears you have
to imbue that in English so you have to
do like nine different voices I had to
feel nine different voices and just
every religion out in the world yeah and
I'm not trying to be disrespectful of
course any religion obviously but like
this is what I was told yeah and I was
like okay this is really hard because I
am unfamiliar with some of the ones
we're mentioning and I was like do I
just just they're like you're fine just
you know so they wheel out the TV and
I'm looking at it and I'm like okay
let's go and it was I sat there and I
said well you know what just give it
kind of a general stage voice and I was
like okay stud I was like the heavens
have spoken and we can delete and
recover all universes and they're like
it's not a question I was like no I know
I was just reading that
I was like all right can I try that
again and they were like yeah but we
really couldn't hear you know the voices
I was like what was your voice I was
like was there any one in particular was
it like Santa that I was missing and so
I was like all right so we we do take
two and uh they were like just give it
more and I was like all right all right
so I was like you know the heavens have
spoken and the deletion of universes is
nigh and they were like stop it's still
not feeling it and I was like all right
well I learned one thing in theater
school it's way easier to tell someone
to do uh less than it is to encourage
people to do more yeah also good for
teaching advice you know it's it start
them off as big as you can and say
that's amazing let's keep most said but
scale it back so I went full Dynasty
Warriors like three with it I was like I
was like if they want to hear the voices
I'll go with whatever the most
ridiculous and I was like you know I was
like I'll move this a little bit further
I was like the heavens has spoken and
then the girl was like
I was like
the new creation and then they were like
that's great we did that [__] for two
hours
I had the best time of my life I was
like that's great and so uh but then and
I'm not making this up I wish I was they
right around the two hour mark these
like eight or nine dudes came in fully
like robed up with gilded robes on the
top and I swear on all of the voices
that they on one of the pillows they had
a gilded dagger this golden dagger and
they were carrying it to the front for
like a sermon of some sort and she's
like our session's done and I was like
okay am I walking out of here alive or
what's going on and then they tried to
like recruit me into the if they you
know they thought I had the voice and so
they said we could if you want to come
back and do it again you need to be a
member of the the the group and I was
like yeah
I'd love to but I'm hearing some
disagreements so I'm gonna I'll get back
to you on that and they were like here's
a matsuya meal ticket enjoy your day in
addition to the money I was paid okay
I was like oh nice you know yeah I was
like nice beef bowl so even though they
had coupons yeah they do surprisingly
well they did when I did that or maybe
it's only for select for religious cults
so we I had that opportunity and I mean
that's such a long story I kind of
detract I got derailed on my own yeah
yeah so and then you kind of have those
opportunities come up every once in a
while and I've always been of the mine
to like take them fully and and if if
you get some extra money out of it it's
it's cool and then of course you know
that me being in all these weird places
and having all these weird experiences
kind of helped me be ready to do things
I think where I transitioned out of
teaching so that's that was a it was a
long nine years and there was other
weird modeling jobs and there was other
weird kind of like oh so you got in this
whole Rabbit Hole of just modeling then
from this one or or just like odd jobs
yeah the some of the bad ones that you
can still find on YouTube it's like I I
uh I had to do I was like a I was like
an English textbook that they use all
over southeast Asia and Japan and people
will see me on like what I undo now and
streaming and they'll say like I just
saw you in my class today and I'm like
hello cajo which notebook is yours the
blue one or the light blue one and
she'll be like the blue one I'm like
they're both blue
whose notebooks are these
they don't have names
sorry that's mine
which one is yours kahoe the blue one is
both are blue
and then it's like I was like well I
wish I could have that one back or I'm
like welcome to Sunshine Pizza what's
today's offer gonna be but you know
um those are there but I think if you
ask my friends in addition to Japan uh
among my friends group I I have I had so
many random jobs in America that from
like from the ages of 18 to you know
moving it was just an endless cycle of
like its own Netflix series so yeah it
was weird is it just because you say yes
to like everything yeah because I feel
like you do you know yeah I'm here today
and I'll say yes there was three French
guys upstairs
but uh I think for me I got this really
cool advice as a young actor and I think
the hardest thing to acquire is unique
experiences and I think a lot of people
fall into routines and I I do too but I
am always keeping an ear open or you
know some kind of opportunity no matter
what if I can get a unique experience
out of that then I think it's worth
doing absolutely yeah absolutely
yeah that's a good life advice I will
make a bad decision I know it's a bad
decision oh my God the story will be
good though it will be a good day it
will be a fun story that's the best yeah
get something out of it yeah yeah and I
I mean I think that a lot of people have
told me I've had a very colorful life
and a lot of interesting experiences but
I think a lot of those though yeah but
those opportunities do come to a lot of
people I think it's just it's easier to
just be like ah nah I don't want to do
that yeah for sure you know because even
if it seems like kind of trivial and
like not important at the time it most
of the times you think about that you
know five ten years later and you're
like [__] I should have done that I
should have done that El cantare voice
well the problem is you don't know what
crazy stuff you're missing exactly yeah
yeah you might not have been El cantare
oh yeah for two hours I heard it all the
voices of every every relationships
stuff that's happened in Japan that
we'll never get to hear about because
nobody's documenting or talking yeah
yeah exactly it's a weird it's a really
wild ride and uh I wouldn't trade it for
a thing honestly I think
um even though those years were very
hard but yeah
yeah finally at the the ancient age of
39 I've been able to see it through
those those tough Parts but I'm glad it
was in Japan I really do love it here